all right so i think
something is going on this week from the
standpoint of the former president
donald trump and trump supporters i want
to go over it with you right now as many
of you might remember august was
supposedly a very important month for
many trump supporters when donald trump
was supposedly going to be reinstated of
course it's not going to happen but
donald trump is going to be speaking at
a rally in coleman alabama
this saturday after being basically
missing from from the public
in any real way for about a month and in
the lead up to this rally on saturday at
which now listen to this
there are some trump supporters who
believe trump will be reinstated at the
rally in alabama saturday i mean just
you know we don't even have to delve
into that
um but donald trump has done a couple of
interviews in the last couple of days
with sean hannity which we'll look at
first and then with maria bartoromo
which we will look at second um this
first interview
i i really don't know what to make of
this donald trump looks like he either
just woke up
um people emailed me saying trump
actually seemed senile in this interview
trump is rumpled he's disheveled his
right eye is again almost completely
swollen shut which seems to be pretty
common now in the interviews he just
looks like he woke up as the interview
was starting
and started answering the first question
which made very little sense let's just
jump right in
well it's good to be with you sean but
it's a terrible time for our country i
don't think in
all of the years our country has ever
been so humiliated i don't know would
you call it a military defeat or a
psychological defeat there's never been
anything like what's happened here now
if you're wondering what the hell is he
talking about he's talking about leaving
afghanistan which is exactly what he
planned to do he just ran out of time to
do it
you can go back to jimmy carter with the
hostages
yeah so the hot stages were definitely
something that trump looked at very
strongly that right eye almost swollen
shut trump making absolutely no sense
and then it goes from strange optics
to strange substance with trump claiming
that the taliban has been fighting for a
thousand years the taliban was formed in
1994.
uh what is the guy what is this guy
talking about oh we did a terrible thing
but think of what's happening now i've
heard as many as 40 000 americans and
the taliban good fighters i will tell
you they're good fighters we have to
give them credit for that they've been
fighting for a thousand years that's
what they do as they fight the top
so praising the taliban but also a
thousand years ban has circled the
airport and who knows if they're going
to treat us right you know all of them
yeah so making very very little sense
then as if that's not weird enough
in the next segment this is a 92nd trump
rant
related to the criticisms of how trump
planned to do the same thing biden did
in afghanistan
but he's incoherent and he's slurring
and i can't tell what point he's trying
to make
i thought it would maybe run through
bureaucracy it doesn't you need somebody
up there that they're going to respect
so when they say oh he talked to the
taliban you remember they were
criticizing me they criticized me when i
talked to kim jong-un well president
biden told me it's the single biggest
problem we have i said have you ever
called him have you ever i mean listen
the criticism of his conversation with
kim jong-un was trump thought that the
concessions kim jong-un made
mattered that they had any substance
behind them when they're the same
concessions that north korean leaders
have been pretending to make to the u.s
for 40 years
and other presidents know not to fall
for them trump fell for it that was the
criticism no i haven't
he did try but he was not it was not
receptive on the other side but it was
receptive with me now we were supposed
to have a war and probably a very big
nuclear war
i get along with him great and i got
along with him great he doesn't like
biden much i'll tell you that but i
guess this is about supposedly this is
about afghanistan along with him great
and we had no problems you remember that
it was we were virtually remember the
big button versus the little button and
the whole thing let me just we get along
great we had a very good relationship we
met
got no credit for that one
no problem well he accomplished nothing
by the way south korea i got them to pay
billions of dollars billions we're
protecting south korea they're very
wealthy they built the ships they built
the televisions they built they do
everything they're very rich
they were paying us nothing
i got them to pay billions and billions
of dollars because we're protecting them
from north korea and i had a very good
relationship okay so supposedly that was
about afghanistan but then he's talking
about kim jong-un and all sorts of just
completely free it's free association
it's it's it's almost freudian in nature
where the interviewer
yeah the whole thing hannity is asking
questions
but he would almost get the same stuff
if he took a freudian approach where the
psychotherapist says almost nothing and
like doesn't even steer the conversation
at all
okay we'll continue then the vaccine
comes up and trump says yeah the vaccine
is good but freedom is important and you
know if you want wear your mask but yeah
freedom is important but i would i would
love people to take the vaccine in the
meantime
wear your mask if you want but if you
want again
you want your freedoms you have to have
your freedoms right so yeah i mean i
guess all else being equal sure get
vaccinated but freedom
and you know if you want wear your mask
but freedom the freedom part is really
really important and then donald trump
says
now they i i genuinely don't understand
this
it seems that hannity asks trump
what would you do if you were president
right now
and trump seems to say i can't tell you
if i'm running because of campaign
finance
i've watched this clip five times i
think that that's what happened see if
you can figure it out are you
considering a run again in 2024 i'll let
you answer it any way you want but i'll
go back to our original question so
hannity mentions the 24 but then he goes
to a question now that we have
all these americans behind enemy lines
do you have in the 45 seconds we have
left
what what would you do now to help that
with that specific situation
so because the campaign finance laws are
extremely complicated and unbelievably
stupid i'm actually not allowed to
answer that question can you believe it
i'd love to answer it but let me put it
this way i think you'll be happy and i
think a lot of our now that's not true
trump trump can say whether his
intention is to run or not
what he may be referring to in his weird
free association cloud9 sort of way
is that
there may be additional scrutiny upon
all the money being donated to him
if he were to say that he's running but
trump's free to tell us if he intends to
run or not it's weird that he keeps
repeating that okay here now we get i
guess to the answer about what would he
do friends will be very happy but i'm
not actually allowed to answer it it
makes it very difficult if i do
so people you're going to be happy
because i love this country and i hate
to see what's happening would you be
willing
okay so what trump won't tell us what he
would do
and he also won't tell us whether he's
running this man is worshipped
by
tens of millions of americans
and that's a really really scary thought
so that was on hannity
bizarre rumpled crumpled disheveled
swollen interview
and all of this leading up to this rally
he's doing on saturday let's go next to
his interview yesterday with fox host
maria bartoromo
if you're a guy the place you want to go
for better skin is geology one of our
sponsors geology has skin care routines
for men that actually work personalized
for you by a dermatologist whether it's
dark puffy eyes acne oily skin or you
want to protect your skin geology can
help you take their quiz a dermatologist
matches you with a unique skin regimen
designed for your specific needs you'll
get a 30-day trial with the treatment
they recommend if you like it they'll
keep sending it to you it's not a magic
cream or bogus miracle whatever these
are just clinically evidence-based
products used by dermatologists tailored
to you
by a dermatologist you're only getting a
treatment that you actually need
i took the quiz the dermatologist
matched me with a treatment it's working
great i love how my skin is looking you
really can see the difference go and
take geology's free quiz
and when you use my link right
underneath this video you'll save up to
40 percent on your first month